hello my name is Gary Coleman managing
director for global indices of Deloitte
Touche Tohmatsu
this is my second time here at the India
forum and first of all I always enjoy
the Indian forum last year was done in
Mumbai this year it's up in New Delhi
the participants are great the
discussions are robust and there is
actually a pretty good international
representation here now this year I had
two two speaking roles at the forum one
was a private session on manufacturing
and the other was a public session that
just finished on the future of
manufacturing and in both sessions the
room was full the participants and the
conversation was robust it was very
straightforward there was a mix of
government officials and private
enterprise in the room and as you
command they didn't always agree but
they did agree to listen to each other
and then they also agreed to listen to
their comments their recommendations and
I felt that the whole session was pretty
good and that was the feedback that I
got out of it just one other related
comment in terms of what did I get out
of the session this week well first of
all you meet so many different people
and you have very short meetings 10-15
minutes you exchanged business cards and
there's always a topic always a
follow-up there's always a business
purpose or a public policy purpose for
exchanging the business cards and I
found from last year and this year that
there's always follow-up the other
interesting thing is that in some of the
sessions you just you just get a feeling
that there is no particular stakeholder
or single stakeholder that can actually
get something done what what I heard
throughout the last couple of days is
that a variety of stakeholders whether
that's government and private enterprise
whether that's union employees there is
common ground to be made both parties or
three parties amongst a three-way
conversation they're listening to each
other and they're listening to their
problems they're listening to their
recommend recommendations and to their
solutions and the one phrase that I
heard
here more than anything was let's get
something done let's define our problems
and let's not write or another report
but let's actually get something done
that's going to benefit India the people
of India the Government of India and
their free enterprise of India and
that's something that I heard throughout
the day